hi Samuel leaves here and I wanna show
you and tell you exactly the difference
between bad debt and good debt because
if you can't get your head around this
and apply what I teach you in this video
it could be the difference between you
being very very wealthy or financially
crippled and wrapped up in bills and
awful awful financial things so you need
every investor needs to understand the
difference between these two types of
debts so good debt what is good debt
well let me give you an example a buy to
let mortgage if you take out save
seventy five thousand pounds to buy a
hundred thousand pound house and your
mortgage payments are two hundred pounds
a month you have to pay that right no
you don't pay that your tenant pays it
and your tenant pays more good debt is
not paid by you good debt is paid by
somebody else you see the definition of
good debt is money that you borrow to
put into an asset and the definition of
an asset is something that puts money in
your back pocket every single month what
happens if it goes wrong well if you
borrow money to buy an asset and it
doesn't really work out as you hoped
then you sell that asset and you pay the
death no problem now bad debt is when
you borrow money to buy a liability can
you just sell the liability and pay off
the debt
no because the liability is usually gone
like free I'll give you an example if
you borrow money to buy it
a holiday and then you have the holiday
and then six months later you've been
got to start paying off the debt you
can't sell that holiday because you've
done it it's gone it's finished
if you borrow money even to buy a car
the car unless it's a collection the car
will shrink in value as the last time I
checked it the car will not give you any
rent so you can't sell the car to then
pay off the debt but if you're buying an
asset the assets going to make you
management and at worst case if it stops
making you money you then sell it and
pay the debt off so that's that's the
difference between good debt and bad
debt let me give you some examples of
how this might look at how this might
operate so firstly good death let's say
that you borrow ten thousand pounds off
a friend and you put
down on a deposit on a house and you
give you friend back 10% so you say
friend I want 10,000 pounds I'll give
you 10% guaranteed return on investment
but the property that you buy is giving
you 20% return on investment that means
that you and your friend are both going
to make the same profit each month as
one another even though he put all the
money in but you make the same amount of
profit and you owned the house he
doesn't own the house we call that a
win-win you've got a big win because you
own the house you put in nothing you're
making money the same as he's making it
on a monthly basis he puts all the merit
because you've leveraged good debt it's
also good for him because 10% is like a
lot lot better than the back so that's
good debt but the problem is people
think in their minds no look that's bad
that's bad my parents to him with the
debts bad but same debt is bad is
moronic because we're talking about good
debt or we're talking about bad debt
it's like saying people are bad no
there's some good people there's some
bad people the reason people get so
scared is because the worst kind of bad
debt is when you borrow money to pay off
bills because if you can't afford to
live and then you borrow to then live
how are you gonna afford to then pay
that debt off which means that you're
going to be even worse off financially
and it's a downward spiral and the
really sad thing and the scary thing is
that is exactly what the banks want they
want broke people in debt struggling to
paid off having to borrow more money
that's what they want and you know if
you go to a bank and you say to a but if
you say to a bank hey can I please
borrow ten thousand pounds it's going to
be for a deposit on a house they'll say
no that's too risky but then if you say
to the same bank and the same manager
hey I'm looking for ten thousand pounds
to get married they'll say no problem
what so it's too risky to put that 10
thousand pounds down to buy a house a
really good investment property even
though you're a real smart investor but
to put it into a wedding is fine
something's not right there something is
absolutely not right and the reason is
is because they want you to spend badly
they want you to invest poorly so that
you
then dependent on them and that is how
they make money off you so it's I could
spend a lot of time talking about this
I'm not a big cynic or anything but I
know how this stuff works
it's it's the same as you've got a
credit card debt and you know say you've
got ten thousand pounds on your credit
card there's companies that will say hey
you know come and transfer all your
credit card debt over with us and we'll
let you have it zero percent you can
have a zero percent interest for two
years which sounds like they're the
heroes and the saviors which they are if
you're a slight investor because they
are I know people that have bought
houses on credit cards literally bought
a house on a credit card transferred the
debt over to a 0% credit card and then
paid the debt off with the rent we call
that genius but the reason that they'd
let you do that is because they assumed
that you are stupid because they assume
that you'll transfer all this debt over
with them they'll give it you interest
free for two years but then in two years
you won't have managed to pay any off in
fact you'll be even further debt and
then they'll bail you through the notes
and charge you 19 percent they were
assuming that you're stupid they were
assuming that you're broke which is
average most people are stupid and broke
but if you're but you just you know
numbers don't lie you just have to look
around to see that to see that what most
of how most people live most people are
in debt most people do not have money in
their bank most people are working 9:00
to 5:00 most people are working 40 years
for 40 hours a week to retire on 40% of
what they couldn't afford to live on in
the first place because of that horrible
trap that bad debt can lead you into
your parents then said debts bad all
that's bad and then you you can't get
your head around the idea of having good
debt so you thought you turned down the
opportunity of good debt forgetting that
nearly all successful businesses and
nearly all successful investors and
entrepreneurs run their business off of
good debt so if you've got a load of
equity in your house refinancing your
house and then the money that you get
from the refinance investing that in
multiple properties is a probably a very
smart thing to do if you do it properly
because the money that you'll make from
those properties you can then pay the
extra interest and have way
water live on and have a way better
monthly cash flow cash is king so you
know paying off the mortgage super smart
and and then and then and then sitting
on the house and then saving up money in
the bank and then sitting on money in
the bank is stupid it's like putting
money under your bet our money shrinks
in value over time as cost of living
goes up the Malou stays the same so you
want to leverage other people's money
you want to leverage the bank's money
just like how the bank like to leverage
your money so I hope that's got you
thinking I'd love to know your thoughts
below if you're in debt and you're in
bad debt right now there I have done a
video talking how to get out of bad debt
and why not to focus on the problem so
if you're in debt and you're in bad debt
you can check out the video should be a
link just pop up just above my head and
love - any thoughts comment below
subscribe share this video as well
because people need to know this message
people need to be aware and wake up to
what the banks are doing and to the
difference between good debt and bad
debt so share this video around to your
friends I hope to see you soon god bless
thank you so much for watching if you
benefited on that video please do share
it with your family and friends for more
videos like it you can watch right here
and if you'd like to spend two days with
me at the property investors crash
course watch this video see what happens
but whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe right here and I'll see you
next time